Háesin về chúp Bình đại học há vật với nhiều thành tích xuất sách thình thạc mũ tủ tiếng
trên được đàn tranh vía g orchestral bíu lông còn có nhiều dài hưởng thế thang lui bật.
Yt này trước, phân linh Lan Mui Bai tuổi, host sinh chương quốc tế Good Còn Cô đi A' Hà Nội,
nhận tin chúng tuyển đại học há vật.
Làmu trong tảm đại học ipilic, nhóm tin phà của Mỹ, đồng thời đa đường thứ 3 trong bảng sẽ hãng tôm nhất thế giới
theo tham Hà yếu Edu Cacen.
Từ lấp sáo, làm đặt sách định dù học Mỹ, trong ba năm đầu chung học cơ dở,
nữ sinh ôn ACT, bà thí trình hoá được đại học Mỹ sử dụng điều kiểm tra năng lực
ứng viên và đặt số điểm 8000 tăng ba mề sáo.
Chân chương, linh lan học chương trình dự bị đại học APE cho học sinh Trung học
phổ thông quế mùi hai một. Nữ sinh nôn duy chi điểm ở mất gần trình đối.
Nhoài ra, nữ sinh hành quẩn còn điểm đá mê với hỏi nữ, có khả năng nói tiếng Anh,
tế bà nhà, pháp bà Trung thành khảo.
Chỉ linh, mẹ của linh lan dựng sẽ khẩn gái làm người kỳ lột, làm việc có kế hoạch.
Ở cách chương hơn 2,5 kỳ lúc mết, mỗi người lan đều phải dưới nhà tụi bà nhà dự kếm,
tới 1 chiến tình 2,5 người dự mới vình.
Dù vậy, chương ngày nào APE tự thề thông, những người bật,
lăng sẽ sản y thu dị trẻ bộ, có nhiều thế gián hơn sẽ tự phòng gì.
Cô tưởng dành là thí trương về bống đã, bóng dầu, điên kinh, bơ lộn lửa tổy của BBAS-OF-OV-E-S-E-A,
tổ chức của khoảng 5,5 kỳ ăn tổ chức. Ngày nhận tiên chúng thuyền,
lan tự tiên và bà lĩnh hơn, có thể đứng nói trước đám đông,
đều phối nhiều hạt động trong các ngoài chương.